mes chers collègues je vous propose que
nous commençons cette
cette commission qui a plusieurs points
à l'ordre du jour mais je voudrais
vraiment souhaiter la bienvenue à toutes
l'équipe d'Action Logement voilà qui est
là je vais vous présenter pour cette
audition qui a un grand succès voilà
aujourd'hui ça fait longtemps que nous
souhaitions vous accueillir donc mes
chers collègues nous avons donc le
plaisir d'accueillir aujourd'hui
Monsieur Bruno arcadiepan président
d'Action Logement
au nom du Medef accompagné de Monsieur
Philippe Langrand voilà vice-président
au nom de la CFDT et de Madame Nadia
Bouillet que tout le monde connaît bien
directrice générale pour faire le point
sur la situation du groupe paritaire
mais aussi sur les négociations avec le
gouvernement vu de la
signature parduro en tout cas de la
conclusion de la convention quinquennale
vous savez que notre commission suit
avec beaucoup d'attention le devenir du
groupe Action Logement que nous
considérons comme un élément central du
pacte social
après guerre et comme appartenant
pratiquement au patrimoine de la nation
du fait de son importance dans nos
territoires avec plus d'un million de
logements sociaux le groupe Action
Logement va fêter cet été c'est 70 ans
et nous sommes convaincus que
l'investissement des entreprises dans le
logement des salariés reste d'actualité
au moment où la crise du logement
s'approfondie et où le pouvoir d'achat
est en berne d'ailleurs on voit beaucoup
d'initiatives d'entreprises qui
aujourd'hui sans passer par le action le
1% enfin l'ex 1% logement construisent
directement des logements pour pour leur
salarié c'est pas très bon signe le
président de la République courtise les
grands groupes étrangers pour
réindustrialiser notre pays nous
voudrions que comme nous il soit
soucieux de défendre la première
foncière européenne qui est française
c'est à dire Action Logement après les
craintes des dernières années le combat
que nous avons mené pour faire échec au
démantèlement du groupe
n'est-ce pas Valérie et Dominique cette
menace est revenue à travers le
classement en administration publique
dans le jargon par Lindsay en août
dernier de la filiale Action Logement
service qui notamment collecte et
distribue la participation des
employeurs à l'effort de construction la
fameuse Pecq ce classement qui pourrait
apparaître comme une simple mesure
statistique statistique et technique à
en réalité un caractère stratégique
puisqu'elle repose sur le fait que les
ressources tout particulièrement l'Apec
et les emplois DS auraient un caractère
public et qui conviendrait donc de
rattacher cette entité à la comptabilité
publique selon les normes européennes
aussi bien en termes de prélèvement
obligatoire de dépenses que de dettes
publiques or une appui sauf exception
prévue par la loi ne peut plus faire que
des empreintes trésorerie sur 12 mois
maximum et Bercy s'est mise dans sa
gestion pour garantir l'équilibre des
ressources et des emplois comme dans un
ministère cela reviendrait donc à
détacher à ls du reste du groupe en
mettant la paix et sa gestion sous
tutelle direct de l'État et non plus des
partenaires sociaux face à cette
situation Action Logement a formulé à
recours gracieux que nous en parlerai
certainement puis il y aura un recours
contentieux contre la décision du
directeur général de l'Insee où en
êtes-vous de cette procédure monsieur le
Président assez inhabituel sur un tel
sujet par ailleurs le ministre des
comptes publics devrait normalement
prendre acte par un arrêté de la
décision de l'INSEE en inscrivant à ls
sur la liste des organismes divers
d'administration centrale or là aussi à
ma connaissance il ne l'a pas encore
fait monsieur le Président vous avez été
récemment reçu par Bruno Le Maire
pouvez-vous nous dire ce qu'il en est
ressorti parallèlement à ces discussions
difficiles Action Logement est toujours
en négociation avec le gouvernement pour
la conclusion de la convention
quinquennale mais alors que les choses
semblaient pouvoir se conclure assez
rapidement avec le précédent
gouvernement nous avons l'impression de
l'extérieur qu'il n'y a plus de
calendrier
l'USH attend son pacte de confiance
promis depuis un an les acteurs de
l'immobilier attendent les arbitrages et
de CNR en conférence des partis c'est
tout un secteur économique qui a
l'impression d'être négligée et en tout
cas loin des priorités alors que le
logement est le premier poste budgétaire
des français qu'en est-il donc de la
convention quinquennale des futurs
emplois des ressources du groupe alors
que les lettres de cadrage ont déjà été
envoyées en vue du PLF 2024 annonçant 5%
d'économie et donc l'idée de ponctionner
j'allais dire à nouveau Action Logement
voilà madame messieurs des premières
questions et avant de vous laisser la
parole je tiens à préciser que notre
réunion est diffusée en direct sur le
site internet du Sénat et relayer par
les réseaux sociaux monsieur cadipone
vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
merci pour vos mots merci
également pour cette introduction
extrêmement précise de de la situation
mesdames les sénatrices monsieur les
sénateurs merci d'être venu aussi
nombreux ce matin cette audition votre
présence montre à quel point la
situation est à la fois grave mais aussi
tout l'intérêt que le Sénat que cette
magnifique maison porte à la fois à
axiologiquement mais à l'ensemble du
monde du logement social intermédiaire
abordable de façon générale mais
également au monde économique au monde
de la de la construction notamment qui
passe des moments extrêmement difficiles
un peu comme nous d'ailleurs pour ne
pour ne rien vous cacher et on va y
revenir
de façon extrêmement précise
vous vous l'avez dit madame la
Présidente Action Logement à 70 ans on
fêtera le 11 juillet prochain
cet événement j'espère que on aura la
chance de pouvoir le faire dans des
conditions normales et de fait comme il
se doit un moment aussi important d'une
vie d'une entreprise
vous avez évoqué plusieurs des
problématiques
graves pour ne pas dire
essentiel à la vie et à la faire revivre
certaines de nos filiales vous avez cité
accent logement services mais ça va bien
au-delà de tout ça et je le dis avec une
certaine gravité lorsque l'on touche
l'établissement financiers les le cœur
du réacteur c'est à dire le financement
du logement social et donc le
financement du groupe à travers Action
Logement service et tout le groupe axi
logement que l'on que l'on touche et
fait la totalité du groupe de ces 19
000 salariés
de son bilan économique etc dans sa
globalité pour près de 100 milliards
d'euros d'actifs aujourd'hui un million
100000 logements vous l'avez rappelé
également nous sommes la plus grosse
foncière d'Europe mais nous sommes
surtout une structure devenue depuis
quelques années maintenant extrêmement
efficiente et si vous le permettez je
vais vous rappeler quand même en deux
mots le cheminement de de cet
institution qui est devenue Action
Logement au cours de ces de ces 70 ans
en accentuant évidemment mon propos sur
sur les dernières années Action Logement
est né de l'idée de quelques chefs
d'entreprise industrielles du nord de
financer
les logements de leurs salariés il y a
plus de 70 ans aujourd'hui puisque on
fête là
les événements 53 mais ça a été une idée
qui a c'est une idée qui a démarré un
tout petit peu avant et c'est une idée
que l'État à l'époque avait souhaité
prendre à son compte
car l'édier était formidable et elle le
reste aujourd'hui Axel logement est un
groupe paritaire vous l'avez souligné
également mais qui était un groupe
extrêmement dynamique
dans les faits
c'est un groupe depuis toujours qui est
dans le fer mais c'est un groupe qui a
énormément évolué et depuis 2017 donc je
fais un raccourci très rapide parce que
le temps nous est compté depuis 2017
nous avons souhaité réunir toutes les
forces vives de la structure dans un
groupe qui
puisse sa source sur les territoires qui
continuent à puiser toutes ces sources
c'est à dire pas que la source
financière et effet peut-être le message
que nous sommes venus vraiment partagé
avec vous ce matin même si nombre
d'entre vous le savent mais nous sommes
le groupe le plus territorialisé pas que
du logement le groupe
de d'investissement territorial le plus
important mais également le plus proche
des territoires
nous avons gardé
un seul opérateur pour collecter la Pecq
mais pour mieux nous répartir sur
l'ensemble des territoires aujourd'hui
le spectre d'intervention d'Action
Logement est évidemment
des terres du nord faire de nos origines
à Marseille mais également de Mamoudzou
à Mayotte où nous sommes aujourd'hui le
premier investisseur à Pointe-à-Pitre
donc on fait le tour du globe la
directrice générale était il y a
quelques jours à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon je partirai
dans quelques jours signés à
Saint-Martin nous continuons à
développer ce lien avec les territoires
avec une force et une détermination que
nous n'avons jamais remis en cause et
que nous n'avons jamais eu jusque là
donc aujourd'hui pour être très clair
c'est tout ça qu'on veut remettre en
cause
c'est cette vision de la territorialité
notre source
elle est collectée par Alf mais elle
était collectée pourquoi par Action
Logement service pour de l'efficience
aujourd'hui
on collecte pour un montant qui est 4
fois inférieur à celui de l'URSSAF donc
je me rappelle est devenu plancher
devant vous il y a quelques années pour
vous dire mais ça n'est pas possible
qu'on soit ursapisé parce que on est
aujourd'hui extrêmement bon efficace
dans la collecte ça a été admis après
maintes discussions et combat notamment
avec monsieur dussoft qui voulait
urssaffiser la collecte
nous nous avons aujourd'hui la même
problématique avec cette capacité cette
capacité d'emprunt qui va être
totalement
bloqué si nous étions
si il y avait la signature de ce décret
qui nous transformait on a pu donc à
terme en audac et vous l'avez
extrêmement bien dit on ne peut rien
faire dans l'immobilier avec une
capacité d'emprunt à un an et encore
moins avec
cette épée Damoclès de nous donner
sous quel forme et pour combien de temps
cette capacité de continuer à emprunter
donc on serait toujours à la mère fille
d'une décision du PLF d'après pour pour
emprunter ou pas donc ce qui est
extrêmement important
pour une
maison comme le Sénat qui défend les
mêmes valeurs que nous cette cette
France de tous les territoires cette
France égalitaire cette France ouverte à
l'ensemble des
des sujets économiques fait
véritablement nous sommes
à un moment essentiel essentiel pour la
pour le groupe Action Logement et pas
uniquement pour Alf mais essentiel pour
le logement social
essentiel pour la France parce que cette
transformation d'Action Logement en a pu
et très clairement un administration
publique et très clairement la politique
du nœud coulant demain matin nous sommes
étranglés financièrement et c'est
l'ensemble du secteur qui va bouger et
qui va être atteint
donc
l'effifiant ça se mesure et depuis
quelques années on a mis en place
d'abord une nouvelle équipe dirigée par
Nadia Bouillet
et puis tout un tas de curseurs qui nous
permettent de mesurer nos actes sur les
territoires
donc nous avions pour première mission
en 2017 donné par des partenaires
sociaux de doubler notre capacité de
production c'est un objectif atteint
en 2017 nous produisons 24000 logements
près de 50000 cette année nous nous
construisons un logement social sur
trois
nous devions
améliorer notre niveau de performance le
service de près de 40%. je suis en
mesure de vous dire que nous avons
augmenté notre capacité de service de
plus de 50%
plus de 800000 aides sont attribués aux
salariés par an 800
000 aides aux salariés par an donc l'ADN
de l'autre groupe est resté identique on
l'a beaucoup modernisé ce groupe mais on
a toujours gardé cette même vision
de l'aide aux salariés pour se
rapprocher de leur emploi le lien
emploie logement et l'ADN
d'Action Logement donc vous imaginez
qu'elle a été mon émotion lorsqu'il y a
quelques jours le ministre tratal dit
que les deux coups de rabots qui seront
portés encore cette année seront sur le
ministère de l'emploi et le ministère du
Logement quand vous êtes entre
guillemets le garant pour mes pères
entrepreneur je vous l'avais rappelé
madame la Présidente et c'est
essentielle de le dire je suis assis sur
un siège Medef je dois des comptes à mes
pères je suis au Conseil exécutif ils
sont tous autour de la table tous les
représentants des plus puissants de
fédérations ont aujourd'hui un problème
d'embauche
on a besoin d'un outil comme Action
Logement
quand le vice-président il pourra
l'exprimer tout à l'heure
en nous explique que certains pourraient
mieux connaître les besoins des salariés
il a été le patron de la CFDT
Île-de-France
il est l'un des plus grands connaisseurs
des du ressenti des salariés et on vient
nous expliquer que patronat
et syndicat
salarié on pourrait demain matin décider
à notre place et mieux que nous
un peu d'humilité on est fait nous
d'être au plus proche des territoires
quand je disais 19000 salariés répartis
sur l'ensemble des territoires c'est
vrai mais on a aussi des centaines de
mandataires
des organisations syndicales comme
patronales dans les territoires notre
conseil d'administration et démultiplier
sur toutes les régions de France
et je dis bien toutes les régions de
France donc là aussi les remontées sont
essentielles quand je disais on puisse
nos ressources
financières mais également intellectuel
des territoires fait le côté singulier
d'Action Logement on le fait depuis
toujours avec cet efficience qui est
arrivé et qui mesurait donc aujourd'hui
on a donné tous ces tous ces résultats
on les a donnés au plus haut niveau de
l'État on les a donné à tous ceux qui
nous les ont demandé on les a présentés
de façon extrêmement régulière au Sénat
à l'Assemblée
la forme des nationales on est d'une
transparence totale je rappelle
qu'il y a trois commissaires du
Gouvernement
dans tous les conseils d'administration
des structures importantes Action
Logement groupe donc la faîtière Action
Logement immobilier axon logement
services la Foncière Logement tous ces
gens-là sont présents donc le ministre
des Finances le ministre du Budget le
ministre du Logement ne peuvent pas
ignorer la moindre décision prise dans
le groupe Action Logement pourquoi
encore aller plus loin en transformant
Action Logement service en
administration publique pourquoi
imaginer demain faire à notre place
c'est impensable pour les partenaires
sociaux c'est impensable pour les
salariés de cette structure où nous
allons avoir et ça a commencé des
problèmes
un vous imaginez la déstabilisation
auprès des 19000 salariés qui tous les
jours voient dans la presse en temps à
la radio ou à la télévision les
problématiques
s'exposaient comme ça par tout le monde
fait fait
ultra anxiogène
ultra anxiogène pour les 19000 salariés
et mettez-vous à la place des
entreprises qui aujourd'hui n'arrivent
plus à recruter moi je veux bien que
tout le monde soit pour la
réindustrialisation de la France on va y
aider
mais attaquer Action Logement ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que si demain
matin on ne signait pas de convention
avec l'État si faites NQ était une fois
de plus reporté si on la décalé
que se passe-t-il sur visale où nous
allons signer dans les jours qui
viennent le milieu
passeport visal
certaines d'entre vous étaient déjà là
quand on a créé visale et on nous disait
mais pourquoi
ça marche ça marche pas pourquoi
ça décolle pas Vival on fait un métier
de ton nom on a besoin de d'année pour
mettre en place à la fois pour la
construction mais pour que les produits
soient bien compris par notre population
aujourd'hui un million de Vival même le
chef de l'État a dit que c'était un
produit formidable etc notre ambition
dans la convention quinquennale que nous
avons posé sur la table
depuis bientôt un an notre ambition
c'est de doubler deux millions de
rivales demain matin 2 millions de
jeunes salariés d'étudiants qui font
garantis par Action Logement pour
intégrer leur future logement voilà ce
qu'on a proposé on a proposé de
continuer à développer
notre capacité à faire à construire au
moment où on le voit bien le le marché
de la construction va prendre un mur et
il ne se passe rien donc aujourd'hui ce
que je suis
venu vous demander ce que nous sommes
venus vous dire et vous demander fait
une fois de plus votre votre soutien
continuez
à nous donner le droit de faire notre
métier quand on a plus les moyens de ma
matin de soutenir la mobilité
qu'allons-nous dire au chef d'entreprise
mais également aux salariés qui veulent
déménager ou prendre un emploi un peu
plus loin un salarié sur deux
aujourd'hui on mobilité refuse un emploi
s'il a pas de logement donc comment
allons-nous faire on veut
on veut nous obliger à avoir un budget
qui est quasiment dédié ou en très
grande partie au soutien des politiques
nationales on a attendu personne excusez
moi mais on a attendu personne pour
soutenir les politiques nationales on
est le premier acteur et financeur de
l'enru depuis le premier jour
et aujourd'hui on nous dit encore plus
c'est ce qu'on veut nous dire à demain
on a une réunion demain on va nous dire
encore plus à l'enrue encore plus au
Fnac mais Action Logement ça peut pas
être un distributeur automatique vous
voyez on y va on met la carte et on tire
de l'oseille ça c'est juste pas possible
on a des milliers de salariés qui
travaillent au service
des salariés on en a des milliers
notamment chez Action Logement services
si demain on ne fait que donner notre
argent à leur rue à Lana aufnap etc que
font ces salariés aujourd'hui la
mobilité est touchée on va devoir pour
la première fois de l'histoire et là je
le dis avec beaucoup de gravité pour la
première fois de l'histoire on va devoir
fermer une de nos filiales celle de la
mobilité
ma nouvelle ville est aujourd'hui sous
PSE
parce que on a pas le choix on est
responsable vous imaginez ce que ça veut
dire pour un groupe paritaire faire ce
genre de choses prendre ce genre de
décision c'est grave c'est très grave
donc je souhaite de tous mes vœux
que la trésorerie d'Action Logement ne
soit pas centralisée que l'ursafilation
de la paix ne soit pas réalisé que la
signature de ce décret n'arrive jamais
que l'on nous laisse
travailler et surtout pouvoir emprunter
et si demain nous avions même une
dérogation
et là aussi c'est grave une boîte de
notre poids qui ferait fout dérogation
pour avoir le droit d'emprunter
est-ce que nous allons aussi être
obligé d'emprunter à l'AFP à l'after
est-ce que c'est ça qu'on veut demain
Action Logement va emprunter auprès de
l'État enfin je sais pas si il fait ce
que vous vous souhaitez mais en tout cas
les partenaires sociaux tous à
l'unanimité à l'unanimité des fêtes
partenaires sociaux de ce pays sans vent
debout contre ils ont tous écrit
ils ont tous réagi de façon publique
pour le faire
donc je crois et j'en aurai fini que
l'antagoniste qui peut y avoir entre
certaines
décisions prise de position et tout ce
qu'on a fait avant on applaudit on
applaudit les salariés de première ligne
les kéfirs de Carrefour les gens de la
santé etc etc mais si demain on est plus
en capacité de les loger comment
allons-nous faire
je vois mon mon ami Marie-Noëlle dans le
fond de la salle
quand j'annonce que nous sommes prêts à
aider l'accession la propriété et
abaisser le taux à 1% évidemment que je
fais pas plaisir à mes père de du monde
bancaire ou autre mais c'est nécessaire
et dès l'accession à la propriété il
faut sortir les les meilleures d'entre
nous du parc social pour pouvoir
intégrer d'autres populations
voilà et aujourd'hui on arrive plus à
loger les gens il faut plus de 8 ans
pour avoir un logement social à Paris
comment c'est possible comment en est-on
arrivé là
voilà le le
fichier fait ne qui est le fichier des
demandeurs de logement sociaux
il pointait à un million 400000
personnes en 2017 aujourd'hui 2 millions
4 on prend plus de 100 000 personnes par
an
et on veut nous empêcher c'est pas
possible
donc voilà je j'en ai fini
en tout cas je répondrai à évidemment
nous répondrons à l'ensemble des
questions voilà j'ai dû oublier plein de
choses mais je pense que Philippe va
merci ma compléter merci monsieur le
Président je vais je vais vous donner la
parole monsieur Langrand parce que le
cri du coeur du président doit être
accompagné aussi voilà du vôtre
j'imagine merci madame la Présidente je
sais pas Bruno si tu as oublié beaucoup
de choses je pourrais être honnête je ne
crois pas
d'abord vous remercier pour pour
l'invitation et merci de de nous écouter
de nous entendre ce matin merci aussi
madame la Présidente pour vos propos
introductifs
qui correspondent bien d'ailleurs à ce
que nous à ce que nous vivons j'écoutais
avec intérêt votre introduction que
puis-je ajouter aux propos du aux propos
du président dire déjà que mais vous
l'avez indiqué tous les deux c'est
l'année des 70 ans de ce du 1% logement
de de ce groupe et pour être tout à fait
honnête avec vous j'aurais préféré qu'on
fait c'est 70 ans dans un autre dans une
autre situation dans un autre contexte
mais la situation vous la connaissez
malheureusement c'est celle-ci et il
faut qu'on y fasse face
ce Groupe d'Action Logement qui qui est
une entreprise d'économie sociale et
solidaire d'utilité sociale je pense
qu'il est toujours bon de de le rappeler
il est atypique à plus d'un plus d'un
titre mais je pense qu'il faut mettre
l'accent et le président l'a fait sur le
fait que ce groupe soit paritaire soit
totalement paritaire et des groupes
paritaires d'ailleurs il y en a plus
tant que ça dans notre dans notre pays
il y en avait beaucoup plus auparavant
et ce groupe paritaire il faut bien
avoir en tête qu'il a essayé d'épouser
son temps d'épouser son époque et il est
pas resté les bras croisés ces dernières
années il s'est profondément réformé le
président la dit également il s'est
réformé pour être plus efficient pour
être plus efficace pour avoir des
résultats et des résultats au bénéfice
de trois grands acteurs que sont les
entreprises les salariés et les
territoires
et force est de constater que les
résultats sont au rendez-vous je pense
que si on faisait même encore alors
aujourd'hui un arrêt sur image on
verrait malgré toutes les péripéties que
politique que rencontre notre groupe
depuis plus d'un an maintenant et bien
on a toutes nos équipes qui sont sur le
pont et qui ont des résultats ces
résultats ils sont en termes immobiliers
le parc aujourd'hui c'est un million
200000 logements c'est du logement
social très social du logement
intermédiaire c'est aussi un
engagement très fort en matière de
rénovation énergétique et on sait tous
que c'est la priorité aujourd'hui avec
la construction mais la rénovation
énergétique et la priorité d'aujourd'hui
mais aussi de demain avec tout ce qui
nous tout ce qui nous attend je pense
que ce groupe est moteur il est leader
là-dessus je pense qu'il est bon de de
le rappeler et puis ces dernières années
c'est un tiers de de la production du
logement social et c'est aussi des
services
là aussi le président l'a rappelé un
plus de 800 000 services aux salariés
divers et variés et je peux vous dire
que en tant que syndicaliste quand on
rencontre les salariés quand on
rencontre nos militants nos adhérents
mais plus globalement les salariés
aujourd'hui avec son logement ça parle
ça parle parce que c'est énormément de
services qui sont accordés alors on a
parlé de visage et à l'accession sociale
à la propriété il y a les herbes
diverses et variées les uns on a mis en
place un dispositif d'aide aux impayés
de loyer après le covid on a mis un fond
énergie en place donc vous pouvez
imaginer l'aide que ça peut apporter aux
salariés donc
ce groupe il est il est moteur à la fois
sur l'immobilier mais aussi sur sur la
notion de de service alors vous nous
posiez la question madame la Présidente
où en est-on aujourd'hui
c'est un peu ce serait très long et
compliqué de résumer mais ça fait plus
d'un an que ça dure c'est pas quelques
mois ou quelques semaines ça fait plus
d'un an parce qu'il faut il faut avoir
en tête que normalement la NCQ être mise
en œuvre depuis le 1er janvier de cette
année donc vous voyez qu'on est fin mai
et c'est toujours pas c'est toujours pas
fait il faut redire quand même
au printemps de l'année dernière il y
avait un gros un gros travail de
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux je le
dis parce que c'est pas
c'est pas de l'imaginaire les
partenaires sociaux c'est
c'est du vrai débat c'est une vraie
confrontation il y a les cinq
organisations syndicales représentatives
il y a les deux organisations patronales
que sont Medef et ses PME tout ce petit
monde il peut avoir des visions
différentes
divergentes et c'est normal parce que
c'est aussi la démocratie et j'insiste
sur ce point parce que ce groupe c'est
aussi faire fonctionner la démocratie
bien évidemment Bruno et moi on pense
pas la même chose sur un certain nombre
de sujets mais la force de ce groupe
c'est que l'ensemble des acteurs se
mettent autour de la table et
construisent des compromis et la culture
du amis elle est hyper importante et moi
je regrette très sincèrement que ce
gouvernement aujourd'hui il a un peu
perdu cette culture du compromis et je
pense qu'on est au cœur quand je dis ça
je pense qu'on est au cœur des
difficultés que nous rencontrons c'est
pas que de la technique c'est pas que
d'un côté on veut 100 et de l'autre on
veut descend c'est quelque compromis on
trouve et les partenaires sociaux il les
trouve au sein d'Action Logement je
pense que ça il faut vraiment le mettre
en avant et pourquoi on les trouve parce
qu'on arrive à dépasser nos différences
parce que les enjeux sont-elles ils ont
été rappelés derrière c'est l'emploi
c'est le logement et c'est l'avenir de
nos territoires si on n'arrive pas à
trouver des compromis ensemble pour de
tels enjeux je pense qu'on a des soucis
à se faire je vous le dis comme comme je
le pense
alors une fois que les partenaires
sociaux ont eu trouvé cet accord on a
porté c'est un peu notre boulot au
président à moi-même de porter ses
propositions auprès auprès de l'État
bien il me semble avec les ministres
concernés c'est-à-dire monsieur Béchu et
Monsieur Klein l'accord était était
globalement trouvé c'est un accord
équilibré je je le dis le terme que
j'utilise un accord équilibré qui a été
trouvé pour pourquoi équilibrer parce
que il faut quand même rappeler aussi
qu'on a fait de gros efforts de notre
côté c'est à dire qu'on a baissé
énormément nos emplois et quand on
baisse nos emplois ça veut dire moins de
salariés aider donc on va voir en tête
que 300 millions de ponctions c'est
25000 salariés qui n'auront pas d'être
derrière enfin tout ça c'est du concret
c'est pas que des chiffres c'est pas que
des tableaux Excel comme on dit parfois
c'est derrière c'est il y a la vraie vie
et c'est et dans la vraie vie c'est des
entreprises c'est des territoires et
c'est des et et c'est des salariés donc
on a baissé nos emplois et en aucun cas
on a touché aux politiques publiques
elles ont même plutôt tendance à notre
participation aux politiques publiques à
augmenter pourquoi pas d'ailleurs ça
aussi c'est un débat je sais pas si on
d'ouvrir ici mais je pense que c'est
nécessaire voir indispensable que notre
groupe participe pleinement aux
politiques publiques et d'ailleurs il le
fait et le président l'a rappelé que ce
soit la rue que ce soit assez V ou sur
d'autres dispositifs je pense aussi que
et notamment en termes de mixité sociale
on a un rôle important à jouer de faire
en sorte que les salariés retrouvent des
quartiers retrouvent des des villes et
ça participe de de cela alors
aujourd'hui ça coince sur les aspects
qui ont été mentionnés ça coince sur la
pub et d'ailleurs vous nous posiez la
question ça coince sur le niveau
d'endettement
qui nous serait autorisé et
éventuellement aussi sur une
augmentation supplémentaire des
politiques publiques
donc les difficultés sont réelles elles
ne sont pas réservées à l'heure qu'il
est le président rappelait la réunion
que nous aurons demain mais enfin on a
des réunions chaque semaine quasiment
donc c'est très difficile de dire si
demain on avancera mais je peux redire
ce qu'a dit ce qu'a dit le président
c'est à dire la pub touche à notre
possibilité de s'endetter à long terme
et on sait très bien que nos structures
a besoin d'un endettement à long terme
alors on nous dit peut-être qu'il y
aurait des dispositions afin que mais il
y a aussi une conséquence politique et
d'ailleurs vous l'avez rappelé madame la
Présidente la conséquence politique
c'est derrière qu'elle sera ou quel est
le rôle des partenaires sociaux on voit
bien que tout ça serait amené à évoluer
et pas dans le sens que nous souhaitons
vous l'imaginez
quand au niveau d'endettement il est
crucial pour notre groupe de à continuer
la rénovation énergétique la
construction et les services aux
salariés et d'ailleurs une des craintes
que j'ai c'est qu'on c'est qu'on
rabiotte les services aux salariés pour
pour passer sur autre chose qui n'est
pas acceptable pour les organisations
syndicales vous pouvez vous pouvez
l'imaginer alors pour terminer parce que
beaucoup de choses ont été dites mais je
pense qu'on est à un moment là aussi le
président l'a rappelé on est sur un
développement économique un
nouveau un souci de réindustrialiser la
France là aussi il faut être faut être
concret quand on
on participe à au canal senor au
financement du canal senior on y était
il y a peu de temps qui va développer
toute cette partie des des Hauts de
France qui va sans doute développer une
métropole comme Dunkerque ce sera pas
que le canal mais il va y participer
derrière c'est des entreprises c'est un
territoire qui qui revient espérons-le
et c'est des emplois ces emplois on va
ces salariés on va les loger ou comment
et avec qui donc c'est là encore le rôle
d'un opérateur comme Action Logement il
est il est essentiel et d'ailleurs les
élus locaux ont bien conscience de cela
que ce soit région de France que ce soit
les élus territoriaux les collectivités
territoriales tout le monde attend de
nous une participation et on est prêt à
jouer cette participation parce qu'on a
bien conscience que les enjeux sont
énormes que le logement est en crise
vous le savez vous le savez comme nous
et qu'on est en capacité
pas seul mais on est en capacité
aujourd'hui d'être un acteur efficace et
efficient pour répondre à la fois à la
crise du logement mais pour répondre
aussi aux objectifs en termes de
développement économique de rénovation
énergétique etc donc moi très
franchement je m'arrêterai là dessus
bien sûr qu'on défend Bruno et moi et
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux
on est tous des on est tous des
bénévoles dans cette histoire et
d'ailleurs pas que nous il y a des
centaines de bénévoles qui qui œuvrent
sur sur les territoires au quotidien et
bien évidemment qu'on défend on défend
notre groupe on défend le 1% on défend
le le Action Logement mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est plus que ça c'est à
dire qu'on défend aussi on sait qu'en
défendant le groupe on défend aussi la
question du logement et et la question
spécificité aussi du logement et
notamment du logement social à la
française et je pense que ça c'est hyper
aussi important dans dans la période que
nous que nous traversons donc je
m'arrêterai là vous voyez que nous
sommes bien sûr le contexte est
difficile mais nous sommes des acteurs
déterminés avec des objectifs précis on
vit pas sur la Lune les propositions
qu'on fait elles sont complètement
efficientes et
on continue et je peux vous dire qu'on
continuera de de les défendre dans les
jours et les semaines qui viennent et
bien évidemment on espère avoir votre
votre soutien voilà merci encore merci
beaucoup service Président je vais
laisser la parole à mes collègues on va
commencer par Dominique Estrosi Sassone
puis Valérie Létard
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président et Monsieur le
vice-président merci pour pour ces
interventions
vous savez combien ici nous sommes
attachés nous l'avons démontré il y a un
certain nombre d'années lorsque déjà le
gouvernement voulait porter atteinte à
oxion logement à travers la réforme de
votre groupe en voulant légiférer
uniquement par ordonnance et à
l'initiative de la présidente une
mission flash avait été mise en oeuvre
avec de façon transpartisane c'est
important de le souligner avec
Marie-Noëlle avec Valérie avec Viviane
et moi même et je crois qu'on peut
pouvoir dire que à travers cette mission
flash et le fait que on a vraiment
alerté le gouvernement on a pu là aussi
faire reculer autant faire ce peu le
gouvernement aux interventions montre
bien sûr combien votre groupe
aujourd'hui
voilà et dans le collimateur du
gouvernement mais je dirais c'est votre
groupe mais c'est une façon beaucoup
plus générale la politique du logement
qui est dans le collimateur du
gouvernement et depuis 2017
Emmanuel Macron et ses gouvernements
successifs n'ont jamais autant négligé
cette politique du logement on envoie
aujourd'hui les conséquences avec une
crise du logement sans précédent
particulièrement grave mais aussi on
voit combien à chaque fois la seule
vision portée donc sur cette politique
du logement par Emmanuel Macron et ses
gouvernements a été de vouloir réduire
les dépenses publiques et de considérer
que cette politique du logement elle
coûtait trop cher on a vu encore les
récentes déclarations du chef de l'État
qui est quand même dénonce fustige un
système de surdépendance public pour de
l'inefficacité collective je crois que
là tout est dit malheureusement et donc
bien évidemment nous on ne s'associe
aujourd'hui de le dénoncer et on voit
les répercussions que cela a et le fait
que on vous empêche de mal d'agir sera
des conséquences extrêmement graves sur
nos territoires vous l'avez souligné à
juste titre sur les entreprises et sur
l'ensemble des salariés donc moi je
voudrais bien sûr revenir sur sur trois
sujets plus particulièrement celui de la
crise du logement que donc ces derniers
temps beaucoup de coupures de presse
beaucoup de de réactions ont été donc
mises en avant sur cette crise du
logement et en particulier une
intervention qui a été remarquée celle
du président Geoffroy route des yeux il
y a quelques semaines à ce sujet donc je
voudrais savoir plus concrètement
comment aujourd'hui les difficultés
actuelles du secteur de la construction
sont perçus par votre groupe et comment
elle se traduisent dans vos chiffres de
production vous avez cité monsieur le
Président 50000 logements cette année
par rapport à ce qui était donc prévu
par rapport à 2017 mais voilà comment
cela se traduit dans vos chiffres de
production et savoir aussi si comme cela
s'est fait lors de la crise sanitaire
votre filiale à LG sera même de jouer à
un rôle contracyclique comme va le faire
ses décès habitats ou si malheureusement
votre groupe sera empêché par l'absence
de convention quinquennale et de
visibilité sur ses ressources concernant
la rénovation énergétique vous avez fait
référence l'un comme l'autre vous savez
qu'il y a au Sénat aujourd'hui une
commission d'enquête sur l'efficacité
des politiques en public en matière de
rénovation énergétique que j'ai
l'honneur de présider je voudrais savoir
quelle est la vision de votre groupe
nous avons dans le cas de cette
commission d'enquête fait des
déplacements et nous sommes allés dans
l'Isère ou à l'île d'Abeau nous avons
visité un chantier qui est mené par
l'une de vos filiales dont les coûts de
rénovation énergétique par logement
était supérieur à 60000 euros par
logement
serez-vous en mesure de faire face à ces
enjeux financiers et opérationnels de la
rénovation énergétique de votre parc et
cela sans abandonner la construction
neuve parce que ce qui nous inquiète
aussi c'est une petite musique ambiante
qui ne cesse de monter et qui au
contraire dit que nous n'aurions plus
besoin de construire dans notre pays
mais qu'il faudrait tout mettre sur la
rénovation énergétique des logements ce
que nous ne contestons pas mais je pense
qu'il est absolument indispensable de
continuer à agir sur les deux piliers
celui de la rénovation énergétique de
logement mais celui de la construction
neuve qui est absolument indispensable
dans notre pays et que pensez-vous du
concept de seconde vie des bâtiments sur
lequel un appel à manifestation
d'intérêt vient d'être lancée enfin à
l'automne dernier la décision du
gouvernement de prolonger le prélèvement
de 300 millions d'euros sur les
ressources d'Action Logement pour
alimenter le FNAP et notamment financer
la rénovation énergétique utiliser les
acteurs du logement social certains
regrettant le manque de transparence
dans la répartition de la paix vous y
avez déjà pour partir répondu monsieur
le Président mais alors que se prépare
le prochain projet de loi de finance
cette hypothèque et cette difficulté
sont-ils véritablement aplanis
aujourd'hui et enfin un dernier point
dans la crise sanitaire l'emploi
saisonnier on a vu combien il est devenu
fragile parce que pour recruter
aujourd'hui dans un certain nombre de
nos départements qui font appel à
beaucoup de main d'oeuvre saisonnières
les entreprises doivent principalement
d'abord être en mesure de proposer un
logement et qui est prioritaire par
rapport à l'emploi qu'ils offrent
ensuite en particulier je pense au
domaine de l'hôtellerie restauration je
sais que vous expérimentez bon nombre de
solutions en la matière de la
cohabitation intergénérationnelle entre
les seniors et les saisonniers de la
location de mobil-home dans des campings
municipaux l'ouverture par votre filiale
Inde résidence qui sont dédiées aux
saisonniers mais également aux
chercheurs à Montpellier je crois donc
est-ce que vous pourriez éventuellement
donc nous présenter un petit peu plus
cette boîte à outils sur ce segment plus
spécifique merci
merci beaucoup Dominique Valérie Létard
ensuite Marie Noéline
la présidente et à mon tour et après
Dominique Estrosi bien sûr de
remercier Bruno arcadiepan et Philippe
Langon Eddy associe bien sûr leur
directrice Nadia Bouillet avec son
équipe parce que
effectivement ils viennent de nous
rappeler le parcours qui a été entamé
depuis plusieurs années maintenant par
votre groupe Action Logement
70 ans effectivement un anniversaire
d'un
héritage du pacte social d'après-guerre
Sophie primal a rappelé
c'est c'est des années des décennies de
construction collective d'intelligence
collective entre l'État les politiques
du logement et le monde du paritarisme
c'est un héritage à mon sens qu'il faut
protéger les corps intermédiaires
montrent
leur nécessité au travers du travail qui
est mené il me semble que vous avez
rappelé aussi un point qui est essentiel
c'est quoi votre coeur de métier c'est
quoi votre mission sont les entreprises
c'est les salariés et ce sont les
territoires parce qu'effectivement c'est
dans les territoires et au plus proche
des territoires avec les acteurs
économiques avec les élus mais qu'il
faut agir au quotidien dans un moment et
vous l'avez dit aussi des uns et les
autres ou on est en train d'engager une
profonde mutation économique une
profonde mutation aussi climatique qui
nécessite qu'on réinvente un modèle de
financement pour accompagner la
rénovation thermique des logements pour
accompagner des constructions plus
économes et vous êtes des opérateurs et
vous l'avez montré intéressant de par
leur puissance de feu de par leur
expérience et ça c'est important et vous
êtes évidemment des acteurs
comment dire qui ont montré aussi
combien le chemin a été parcouru pour
montrer que le paritarisme son
organisation au plus proche des
territoires peut répondre à des besoins
de crise à des besoins
immédiats importants avec efficacité en
tout point du territoire alors j'étais
présente à Dunkerque à quelques jours de
ça et le président lui-même de la
République a rappelé quoi bon d'abord
les normes mités du projet de la
nécessité de l'industrie verte de la
transition industrielle crée des usines
à batterie pour avoir des véhicules
propres créer des EPR et que tout ça
allait évidemment amener des besoins en
logement en nouveau salarié qui vont
arriver avec leur famille c'est 20 000
logements qui va falloir créer en trois
à cinq ans dans ce territoire
parce qu'il y a les emplois directs il y
a les emplois induits il y a tous les
services qui vont être créés autour
c'est un territoire sur la seule région
des Hauts-de-France nous avons quatre
projets de gigafactory immédiat d'ores
et déjà lancé vous imaginez les besoins
on avait une réunion sur le zéro
artificialisation nette juste avant
celle-ci qui aborde un autre sujet tout
aussi essentiel quand on parle de
comment avancer sur ces questions
d'abord rénover les logements d'abord
elle est sur les friches mais on sait
pas que ça sera pas suffisant mais
surtout quand on parle ici d'un
opérateur dont le cœur l'ADN et le
logement des salariés les services
rendus aux salariés
imaginez qu'on puisse mettre en
fragilité classée on a pu un organisme
qui a besoin de marge de manœuvre
marge de manœuvre financière non pas
pour faire n'importe quoi tout a été
redressé depuis des années tout a été
fait effectivement pour que les choses
aillent mieux alors je me permets de
dire ça parce que Dominique Lady il y a
des années qu'on s'est penché sur la
question d'Action Logement dont on
s'interrogeait sur l'efficience
l'efficacité l'utilité
ni l'autre ni aucune d'entre nous non
d'action dans ce groupe ou d'intérêts
particuliers simplement c'est un
opérateur
parmi d'autres l'USH les organismes de
logement sociaux qui concourent à une
politique du logement à la française ou
de l'avait dit logement et logements
social ce qui me choque ce qui me gêne
et je témoigne toujours fortement sur
ces questions parce qu'on les a abordés
avec détermination et collectivement
avec Marine Noël Viviane Dominique
depuis des années ce qui me choque c'est
que aujourd'hui le gouvernement en vient
à pratiquement opposé les univers du
logement pourquoi pour régler un
problème budgétaire qui est et bien pour
accompagner les attentes d'un secteur
tels que le logement social par exemple
et bien il faut aller effectivement
trouver des économies et des marges de
manœuvre et on va aller chercher dans un
autre univers du logement or on a besoin
non pas effectivement de réduire les
capacités budgétaires globales et
rassembler de tous les secteurs du
logement on a besoin que l'État remettre
toute sa certes l’état a besoin de faire
des économies budgétaires et de réduire
les dépenses publiques mais vous l'avez
dit Monsieur Attal effectivement a
choisi de remettre une fois de plus sur
le devant de la scène comme étant la
variable d'ajustement budgétaire du
projet de loi de finance prochain
l'emploi et le logement est-ce bien
raisonnable Action Logement est un
opérateur qui mobilise de l'argent du
paritarisme pour le logement si demain
on met en difficulté ou on remet
effectivement comme structure pilotée
par l'État administration publique un
opérateur comme Action Logement ce sera
pourquoi faire comment les moyens vont
être mobilisés comment ça sera fait avec
les représentants des salariés avec les
territoires on peut se le demander moi
aujourd'hui c'est pas une critique du
gouvernement que je souhaite
aborder c'est juste que le gouvernement
que le gouvernement
mette des moyens supplémentaires mais
n'aillent pas faire secteur du logement
pour abonder ce qu'il ne souhaite pas
mettre dans un autre secteur du logement
je le dis fortement parce qu'au moment
où on est en crise opposé ces univers
mais des salariés précaires il y en a
combien qui vont avoir besoin de
financement du logement des salariés
donc voilà mon messager fort mais je
vous l'avais dit le ministre Béchu et le
ministrelin ont travaillé la copie avec
vous elle est prête à être signée et
bien maintenant on attend que le
gouvernement le président de la
République la première ministre le
ministre du Budget entendent que il est
temps de signer la convention
quinquennale et qu'il est temps de
remettre les moyens dans le secteur du
logement et de laisser axiologiquement
faire son travail remarquablement voilà
avec engagement Valérie
[Applaudissements]
Marie-Noëlle lineman et ensuite
Jean-Baptiste après ces plaidoyer
permettez-moi d'y ajouter ma pierre
peut-être avec un certain nombre de
nuances en tout cas d'exigences pour
l'avenir si on veut préserver justement
cet outil paritaire il vous aura pas
échappé que depuis pas mal d'années et
surtout depuis l'arrivée de Monsieur
Macron toutes les structures paritaires
ont été les unes après les autres
désossées remise en cause or pour moi ça
fait partie d'un ADN du modèle français
issu de l'après-guerre et qui avait
quand même marqué c'est son efficacité
dans bien des domaines
donc de fait comme d'ailleurs la sécu
c'était historiquement un prélèvement
obligatoire donc de fait Action Logement
n'est pas simplement un acteur parmi
d'autres il est un acteur qui doit
porter une part de l'intérêt général et
pas simplement la défense d'un seul
secteur puisque tout le monde y
contribue prélèvement obligatoire et je
vais prendre l'exemple des HLM
vous nous dites à juste titre et c'est
vrai qu'il y a eu un très beau travail
qui a été mené pour doubler la
production
sauf que quand vous êtes un acteur
d'Action Logement vous bénéficiez d'un
accès à des fonds propres aisés et un
certain nombre de subventions ou d'être
qu'un certain nombre d'autres organismes
qui soient dysophile des autres et ça je
vous parle pas des coopératives qui ont
locatives sont pas gigantesques non
bénéficient pas
et d'ailleurs le rapport de la Cour des
comptes a bien montré que l'argent
d'Action Logement n'était pas
équitablement répartis pour ce qui est
du monde HLM entre les opérateurs HLM
donc ça il faut que ça il faut que ça
évolue
il faut que ça évolue sur un autre champ
qui est que quand vous bénéficiez d'une
aide d'Action Logement
l'attribution est fait par Action
Logement
et pas par d'autres acteurs notamment
les collectivités
donc la différence entre une subvention
qui passe par le snap et une subvention
qui passe par Action Logement c'est
quand vous êtes un maire celle qui vient
du Fnac c'est la répartition du
contagion publique et général quand vous
êtes financé par action de logement
c'est Action Logement qui décide de
l'attribution pour une part renforcée
donc on a beaucoup d'élus locaux qui
considèrent que certes il faut loger les
salariés mais ils ont des salariés dans
leurs offices ils ont des salariés dans
leur état ils ont des salariés tout ne
peut pas passer par Action Logement donc
ma préoccupation c'est mon souhait mais
je sais bien que mon souhait n'est pas
là forcément le choix de tous mon
souhait c'est quand même que la
participation d'Action Logement ou snap
ce qui nous dispense pas d'exiger
l'intervention de l'État parce que
l'aide à la pierre est devenue tellement
faible dans ce pays que ça devient
insupportable je considère et je
voudrais vous interroger ce que dans vos
propositions vous acceptez l'idée d'une
contribution négociée en traction
logement et l'État au final pour
financer le monde HLM pour ma part je
l'ai toujours défendu et je pense que ça
pourrait être acceptable alors je vais
pas être trop long parce que je sais
qu'il y a d'autres secteurs comme l'enru
je rappelle que Jean-Louis Borloo quand
il a créé la rue avait mis dans le texte
créateur la parité entre l'intervention
d'Action Logement est celle de l'État si
l'état remettait sa somme paritaire avec
son logement pourrait remettre au frappe
au FNAP on voit bien que mais ce n'est
pas qu'une question de masse budgétaire
c'est une question de principe donc
voilà ma préoccupation je ne vais pas
vous refaire mon plaidoyer pour
l'accession sociale à la propriété mais
quand j'entends le président de la
République nous dire qu'il faut
s'occuper des couches moyennes etc et
que ils savent tous les outils de
l'accession à la propriété alors ça
constitue pour beaucoup et une promotion
sociale et un outil de mobilité je
regrette mais je me disais j'espère pas
de convaincre que la prime d'accession à
la propriété pour les ménages modestes
qui avaient été mis en œuvre pourrait
être défendu par Action Logement dans la
convention quinquennale
merci marinelle je vais vous proposer
peut-être de réagir à ces trois
premières interventions et ensuite on
prendra l'ensemble des autres questions
je vais essayer de répondre à ces
multiples questions au moins au moins
sur l'aspect sur l'aspect politique
déjà si j'arrive à rien oublier
notamment au niveau des 150 questions de
Dominique
et puis peut-être que Nadia Bouillet
pourra nous donner quelques chiffres et
quelques exemples extrêmement précis
pour pour répondre à l'ensemble des
questions posées
peut-être
commencer par le la question qui était
posée par la sénatrice exposé ça sonne
sur le
le contexte du de la construction ce qui
nous apporte ce qui m'emmènera ensuite à
réagir sur le reste la situation est
évidemment
dramatique je
l'ai dit à life dernièrement la
construction neuve et
au point mort je vais pas revenir sur
les chiffres calamiteux et notamment en
très grande accélération enfin en
régression profonde depuis ces derniers
mois la construction de façon générale
et
exemple le les permis de construire
c'est c'est - 27 si on prend si on prend
les le premier le premier trimestre etc
enfin on va vraiment
se heurter à un mur et on y va en
klaxonnant mais personne n'entend quoi
et là on est une vraie problématique si
vous rajoutez ça à ce que j'ai dit dans
mon propre introductif c'est à dire
faites demande de logement sociaux qui
croit de façon exponentielle et si on
croit ça avec l'enjeu de rénovation
énergétique dont vous faisiez allusion
madame la fénatrice aussi donc voilà
c'est tout ça qui fait que si vous y
rajoutez en plus un petit peu de
d'inflation des taux qui explosent et
évidemment pour les bailleurs sociaux je
reviendrai pas sur le sur l'impact
l'impact financier que
ça peut avoir
et si vous rajoutez le milliard 3 de RLF
que l'État continue à à ponctionner et
ben on en arrive à un constat super
simple
je vais vous le dire sur 2023 aucun
bailleur social axe logement inclus
aucun bailleur social ne fera un
résultat positif donc c'est quoi le
résultat positif pour un bailleur social
en fait c'est son autofie le curseur
évidemment faut regarder tous les
curseurs techniques mais le curseur le
plus important c'est l'autofinancement
parce que sans ça on fait plus rien et
ben en 2023 aucune structure qu'elle
soit esa chaque son logement office
public faible aura un autophy positif
on est à l'os voilà je peux pas le dire
autrement
tout le monde a essayé de faire des
économies tout le monde a fait
extrêmement attention etc etc mais à un
moment donné c'est plus possible
peut-être que piquer un milliard d'euros
monte du logement c'était faisable sur
un quinquennat mais un milliard trois
par an là on a dépassé les 10 milliards
d'euros depuis 2017 donc à un moment
donné fait comme dans toute entreprise
il y a une limite il y a un curseur un
niveau sous lequel on ne peut plus
descendre et bien on y est mais personne
veut l'entendre donc les dodu dormant
c'est mort mais je peux vous dire c'est
mort depuis longtemps
donc aujourd'hui vous avez des
structures qui réfléchissent à comment
ils vont faire pour financer les trucs
obligatoires c'est à dire l'entretien
des vaffenseurs les des problématiques
de sécurité donc on a
dépassés de problèmes donc évidemment
que derrière il faut gérer la
décarbonation
on veut aller un peu plus loin qu'est-ce
qu'on va continuer à avoir comme moyen
pour aller vers l'innovation le secteur
de la construction est notamment le
secteur
du social est un secteur qui depuis
toujours est à la pointe de l'innovation
si on a plus les moyens de faire ça ça
va être très compliqué de d'aller vers
les obligations que nous avons bien sûr
qu'il faut des carboner bien sûr que on
doit mettre en place le van partout sur
tous les territoires etc etc mais à un
moment donné toutes ces demandes elles
sont impossibles à mettre en place aussi
vite et surtout financièrement donc moi
je veux bien qu'on me parle pas
de l'aspect financier parce que c'est un
peu voilà vous devez assumer vos
responsabilités d'utilité publique ou
sociale mais pour ça on a besoin de
ressources et de moyens donc ce qui
m'emmène à la ressource donc c'est là où
on a un tout petit
une petite distorsion entre Marie-Noëlle
et nous l'Apec ça n'est pas un
prélèvement obligatoire fait un CVO donc
c'est une contribution
obligatoire volontaire
non non mais il y a une différence mais
je vais vous l'expliquer je vais vous
l'expliquer en deux secondes
je vais je vais vous l'expliquer
techniquement en deux secondes vous avez
trois possibilités vous avez trois
possibilités de verser la pêche
soit par une contribution normale
financière donc ce qui pourrait
ressembler là à un prélèvement
mais c'est loin de faire 100%, très loin
de faire
100%. vous avez des gros groupes
donc le gros de la Pecq pour être clair
qui préfère nous prêter de l'argent
donc il ne verse pas de une contribution
il nous prête de l'argent
sous forme d'un d'un très bonifié si
vous voulez qui lui correspond
à
une contribution en termes financier
mais c'est un prêt c'est à dire que dans
nos comptes et dans ceux des boîtes
il y a évidemment un actif
il y a un actif c'est pour ça qu'action
logement service est un et un
établissement financier assujetti au
contrôle de la CPR comme toutes vos
banques
voilà et il y a une troisième
possibilité et vous l'avez dit madame la
Présidente il y a aussi possibilité de
construire en direct ces logements c'est
ça la différence entre un prélèvement et
puis j'irai même plus loin vous voyez
j'irai même plus loin nous 100% de notre
source elle vient des entreprises des
entreprises de plus de 50 salariés
sans pour cent on n'a pas d'argent qui
tombe du ciel fait les entreprises qui
décident si demain si demain
ces dernières données pour mandat aux
futurs présidents du Medef d'aller voir
le ministre des Finances et de
renégocier ça à la baisse ou à la hausse
etc etc c'est là c'est pas l'état qui
décide un prélèvement c'est une
discussion on n'est pas dans le cadre
d'un prélèvement c'est une négociation
donc moi ce qui me fait très peur c'est
qu'à force de jouer à force de jouer
avec l'Apec ce qui vous fait très peur
c'est qu'à un moment donné on fatigue
aussi c'est très gros contributeur
on parle de dizaines de millions d'euros
pour certaines structures de
contribution donc de centaines de
millions de prêts pour celles qui font
des prêts et si demain on devait arrêter
les actifs de ces entreprises que
deviennent-ils on va demander à des
entreprises françaises de détruire une
partie de leur bilan
donc attention à ne pas jouer avec le
feu parce qu'on va vraiment finir par se
brûler
donc
ensuite la différence entre
lorsque nous dit nous traitons les
dossiers et quand d'autres le font pour
nous et notamment si demain c'était
Bercy
on a attribué on a
distribué depuis 70 ans 100% de notre
recette au service des salariés et à la
construction
demain matin je
je vous garantis que ça fera plus 100%
et ça partira ensuite je vais juste vous
rappeler un exemple il y a quelques
années il y a quelques années j'ai signé
avec Bruno Le Maire vous voyez des
acteurs changent pas beaucoup j'étais
déjà président il était déjà ministre
des Finances quand la loi pacte passe
on nous demande rien mais on est quand
même impacté 300 millions par an
différence des versements des
entreprises de 20 à 50 on dit il y a pas
de problème on va vous compenser bien
sûr on a fini un accord on a été
compensé une année
non
donc vous voyez quand
je vous voyiez quand on nous dit on nous
dit on va vous donner l'autorisation
d'emprunter
n'ayez pas peur ça va bien se passer on
va vous donner une dérogation mais une
dérogation combien de temps une fois un
an non donc c'est pour ça que la
situation
la situation est extrêmement grave et je
rajouterai peut-être quelques détails
vous savez l'Insee fait pas l'Insee qui
pilote la France quand même
l'Insee déjà dépend aujourd'hui
d'eurostate donc c'est au niveau
européen et je rappellerai un truc très
simple ni le ministre des Finances ni le
ministre du budget n'a de compétences
liées avec ce sujet donc c'est pas une
obligation de ça n'est pas une
obligation de signer et puis
pour finir il y a plein de moyens de de
redonner du souffle à secteur des
facteurs économique vous voyez j'ose
dire qu'on est un secteur économique
une baisse de l'arlf pourrait très bien
financer un bout du snap et un bout de
l'enru pourquoi toujours venir taper sur
les mêmes
actions logement pourraient bénéficier
de 100% de sa ressource et et l'État
reprendrent les manettes remettre de
l'argent aux rues remettre de l'argent
au pot au NAP chacun dans son rôle et
chacun avec ses compétences voilà
peut-être que Nadia tu veux t'exprimer
sur les les féveniers mais c'est un
sujet qui nous tient à cœur partout on a
rencontré tout le monde sur les
territoires pour savoir comment nous
pouvions faire j'étais encore avec Bruno
Retailleau sur son territoire de Vendée
pour voir un constructeur de logements
que l'on pourra déplacer
et qui vont là aussi apporter des
solutions aux territoires et juste pour
finir les GO Factory du Dunkerquois et
le canal fait Nord là aussi
Philippe longran la souligné mais là là
aussi fait démentiel c'est des dizaines
de milliers de salariés qui arrivent sur
des territoires qui n'ont rien pour les
accueillir donc comment peut-on vouloir
freiner le premier acteur du secteur
lorsqu'on en a tant besoin
je vous engage à peut-être concentrer il
y a encore beaucoup beaucoup de
questions beaucoup énormément voilà très
rapidement j'ai retenu trois autres
trois choses importantes dans les dans
les questions qui nous ont été posées là
la première autour de la crise du
logement la rénovation énergétique
faut-il opposer les deux
faut-il continuer à à construire
effectivement il y a une petite musique
aujourd'hui qui qui
prend enfin qui qui prend un chemin quoi
disons il y a plus besoin de construire
il y a assez de logements comme ça et
puis certains se projettent d'ailleurs
en termes démographique en disant voilà
dans 20 ou 30 ans voilà en ce qui
concerne les partenaires sociaux et j'ai
décidé dans les partenaires sociaux et
Action Logement il s'agit pas d'opposer
les deux il faut construire il faut
continuer à construire parce qu'il y a
des besoins et moi je veux bien qu'on
dise on attend 30 ans mais enfin il y a
des gens qui attend qui ont besoin et ce
sont des millions de personnes qui
attendent un logement aujourd'hui donc
l'urgence n'est pas d'attendre mais
l'urgence c'est de c'est de construire
et l'autre urgence c'est de retrouver
donc politiquement se faire les deux il
faut faire les deux après le
financièrement parlant on va pas
retomber dans tout ce qu'on vient de
dire depuis tout à l'heure concernant
l'action logement si on nous laisse
faire on peut faire on peut faire les
deux et on fera les deux alors avec les
moyens qui sont les nôtres mais en tout
cas politiquement c'est ce qu'on porte
ensuite Valérie a mis l'accent sur
l'opposition au sein de l'univers du
logement je pense que ça c'est essentiel
politiquement aussi à prendre garde à ça
en tout cas moi je vous dis je suis un
de je fais partie de celles et ceux qui
font très qui sont extrêmement vigilants
à ça parce que je fais partie de celles
et ceux qui pensent que ce monde du
logement qui là encore c'est un peu
comme chez les partenaires sociaux on a
nos différents nos différences nos
divergences etc mais je pense que ce
monde du logement social il doit avancer
ensemble il doit aussi trouver des des
compromis c'est difficile tu l'as
souligné d'ailleurs c'est c'est
difficile moi je le regrette et d'autant
plus que je pense que ce gouvernement
qu'on peut accuser de plein de choses
mais ce gouvernement il est très
intelligent il est très habile sur un
certain nombre voilà et il sait faire et
certains je le dis tombe dans le panneau
moi je fais pas partie de ceux qui vont
tomber dans ce panneau là voilà mais
certains je sais sont tombés un peu dans
ce panneau de la division comme tu l'as
rappelé de diviser pour pour mieux
régner dernier point c'est Marine Noël
qui mettait en avant l'intérêt général
alors moi je fais j'ai envie de dire que
depuis que je suis tout jeune et que je
milite même dans ma boîte dans mon
entreprise je vous ai fait délégué
syndical j'ai toujours mis l'intérêt
général au cœur de mes préoccupations et
de mes revendications et je me souviens
d'un vieux militant qui m'avait dit
l'intérêt général tu prends une image tu
vois un mur tu as envie de retirer une
brique ou deux parce que c'est briques
t'intéressent mais si tu prends ces deux
briques le mur risque de tomber ben
c'est ça l'intérêt général c'est de se
dire si je prends quelque chose est-ce
que tout le reste ne va pas tomber bon
donc l'intérêt général
je pense que Action Logement très
franchement il participe pleinement à
l'intérêt général
et quand on dit une part d'intérêt
général c'est plus qu'une part tout a
été rappelé le
enrue un CV le snap la part notre
participation politique publique les
pourcentages ne cessent d'augmenter il
ne cesse d'augmenter donc même moi qui
suis un ardent défenseur de l'intérêt
général faut bien quand même qu'on se
dise qu'à un moment donné notre cœur de
métier je sais plus qui le rappelait
mais notre cœur de métier c'est quand
même de loger les salariés et de
répondre aux besoins des entreprises et
donc on est quand même dans la situation
qui est la nôtre aujourd'hui
à faire en sorte de trouver l'équilibre
entre les deux et force est de constater
que plus les mois et les semaines
avancent plus la part consacrée à
l'intérêt général et et importante et
c'est ce qu'on a rappelé sur le snap
très franchement là aussi on peut avoir
nos différences nos divergences même au
sein même des partenaires sociaux sur
cette question là mais moi je me
souviens l'avoir dit dans le bureau du
ministre du Logement monsieur Klein dès
le mois dès le 2 ou 3 septembre quand on
avait été reçu la la première fois
j'avais dit au ministre alors au bout
d'un moment on commence à se connaître
et dit Olivier écoute moi je suis pas à
Nantes je suis pas contre la
participation d'Action Logement au final
mais à un moment donné il faut bien se
dire c'est l'exemple que je prenais tout
à l'heure si on verse 300 millions il
faut c'est l'intérêt général c'est de se
dire c'est 26000 salariés qui ne
toucheront plus de voilà on peut pas
faire comme si ça n'existait pas ça donc
il faut qu'on trouve les juste
équilibres et je sais que c'est pas
facile mais en tout cas c'est ça qu'il
faut réussir à trouver
merci peut-être Madame la Directrice
générale sur le logement saisonnier
alors juste là je reviens sur vraiment
un focus sur une problématique qui nous
est très chère aussi parce que c'est une
grosse problématique des entreprises
aujourd'hui effectivement la méthode est
qu'on utilise c'est bien une méthode de
partir des besoins du terrain et
aujourd'hui il y a pas un modèle
économique tout fait sur le logement des
saisonniers donc en fait on teste
beaucoup de modèles différents avec je
vais vous prendre plusieurs exemples
notamment Haute-Savoie on a des exemples
de remise sur le marché de de logement
en vacances qu'on a pu aider à remettre
sur le marché pour des logements
saisonniers ou alors l'intervention avec
du logement baudulaire aussi par notre
filiale 3F résidence un autre exemple
c'est le zoo de Beauval qui était venu
nous voir avec cette problématique à
Saint-Aignan avec en disant voilà on a
plusieurs centaines de saisonniers on y
arrive pas et on a fait une étude à ce
moment-là sur l'ensemble du bassin
d'emploi avec les châteaux de la Loire
notamment qui avait la même
problématique et donc il y a un bouquet
de solutions sécurité apportée la
création d'une résidence de 81 logements
dédié aux saisonniers qui qui implantait
qui a été inauguré l'année dernière donc
tout ça on est dans du long cours il
faut un petit peu d'ingénierie pour le
faire et à côté la mise en place
effectivement je dirais de moyens
d'appui pour pouvoir diriger aussi ces
saisies parce que 81 ça suffit pas pour
répondre à tout ça vers une offre de
logement qui va être diffuse que ce soit
effectivement j'allais dire de
l'intergénérationnel ou dans le parc
privé où on va accompagner et accueillir
type agence immobilière à vocation
sociale qui est aussi une autre solution
et alors il y a un autre exemple et ça
je pense que c'est intéressant parce que
c'est des problématiques qui se rend
compte dans beaucoup de territoires qui
se trouvent à Bandol où là on a une
résidence de tourisme qui était laissée
à l'abandon mais la chance qu'on avait
elle était mono-propriétaire parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez beaucoup de
résidences de tourisme
multi-propriétaires qui la pose un sujet
à mon avis de transformation mais
celle-là elle était mono-propriétaires
donc il a accepté de la vendre il y a
une négociation avec notre filiale
Unicil et la transformation là avec une
part d'accession en BRS une part
d'accession aussi maîtrisée et une part
de locatif et ce locatif en fait pour
pouvoir le dédier à des publics et là
c'est plus facile sur la côte parce
qu'on peut avoir du saisonnier en été et
puis pendant le reste de l'année plutôt
des gens en alternance donc ça a été un
partenariat avec le CFA et là on passe
par un système d'intermédiation locative
avec en fait une association là c'est
Solia qui est le gestionnaire qui est
donc ça permet effectivement d'avoir un
des attribution pour ses publics là et
évidemment avec avec l'accord de tout le
monde et là on a 25 logements qui sont
dédiés et on arrive à combiner des deux
usages c'est à dire des saisonniers et
puis des apprentis pendant l'année et
c'est ça qu'il faut réussir à trouver
aujourd'hui aussi et c'est plus
compliqué en montagne ça veut dire qu'il
faudrait presque caler des formations
d'apprentissage sur les saisons où on
n'a pas besoin de saisonnier non mais
donc il faut aller un peu plus loin que
qu'effectivement le seul prisme le seul
prisme logement donc en interne au
groupe on a fait un guide mais qui est
peut-être pas assez connu et qu'on
aimerait bien et on en a parlé avec
Madame Faure relie relayé sur les
territoires pour aussi montrer les types
de solutions qu'on peut apporter et puis
effectivement voilà ouvrir des
réflexions c'est que des réflexions
notamment sur la sécurisation par
rapport à visa parce qu'il y a toujours
effectivement une inquiétude de
dégradation et donc c'est des sujets qui
à mon avis pourraient voilà assez
rapidement rentré dans l'opérationnel
mais on n'a pas un modèle général et
donc c'est c'est la difficulté de ce
type de public
merci Madame la Directrice générale je
vais donc laisser la parole maintenant à
l'ensemble de nos autres collègues on va
commencer par Jean-Baptiste Lemoine puis
Evelyne renaud-garabédian merci beaucoup
madame présidente merci beaucoup
Président je suis président général pour
tous ces éléments j'ai pas eu à
connaître de ce sujet d'appui auparavant
et d'audace mais il y a bien une chose
que je sais pour hélas en avoir vu les
conséquences sur l'immobilier dans
l'enseignement français à l'étranger
c'est que le classement de l'aufe en
ODAC a eu comme répercussion
effectivement un très grand difficulté à
pouvoir procéder à l'extension du réseau
et je parle sous le contrôle de
Jean-Pierre Mansart Régine
renaud-berrabédian je pense qu'ils
peuvent attester de cela donc on voit
bien les conséquences effectivement d'un
tel classement en termes de financement
au-delà de au-delà d'un an ma question à
l'heure des plaidoyer justement était
peut-être aussi d'en faire un pour
un dispositif auquel vous contribuez qui
est celui des agences mental
d'informations sur le logement les Adils
moi je le vois dans l'Yonne il y a là
une petite équipe d'une dizaine de
personnes qui fait plus de 10000
consultations par an et qui voilà
bénéficient aussi parmi ces sources de
financement au-delà du financement de la
cg2ls de l'État également de financement
d'Action Logement et donc il y a cette
contribution de 9 millions d'euros qui
étaient voilà en cours depuis plusieurs
années qui n'avaient d'ailleurs pas été
réévalué et pour lequel les intéressés
ont des inquiétudes et donc je voulais à
travers peut-être vos propos que vous
puissiez les rassurer sur le partenariat
construit entre Action Logement l'ADIL
le partenariat financier on entend bien
tous les sujets que vous avez avec
l'État mais indépendamment de cela je
pense que au regard des montants enjeux
il y a la possibilité d'envoyer ce
signal aujourd'hui très rapidement je
vous remercie
merci ma présidente monsieur le
Président je suis sénateur des Français
l'étranger à ce titre je rencontre
régulièrement des Français qui vivent à
l'étranger et qui nous exposent des
problèmes d'administratifs qui
rencontrent et j'ai deux questions à
vous poser l'une qui est le mobilit pas
qui a été mis en place pour des aides
qui sont à louer à des salariés français
en France et qui déménage pour un
nouveau job est-ce qu'il serait
envisageable d'étendre
ce dispositif aux Français qui décident
de rentrer en France et qui ont trouvé
un over job pour pouvoir les aider dans
le cadre de leur déménagement et dans
leur cas de la recherche de leur
logement la deuxième question elle porte
sur les jeunes Français qui après le bac
rentrent en France pour suivre les
études à cursus universitaire et
rencontre en difficulté énorme en France
pour pouvoir trouver un logement parce
que les bailleurs privés n'acceptent pas
la garantie des parents qui vivent à
l'étranger qui ne sont pas imposées en
France et qui ne peuvent pas justifier
de revenus en France
est-ce que l'on pourrait envisager de
d'avoir des possibilités pour que visale
leur soit consentie je pense que oui la
difficulté c'est que à l'étranger les
Français ne connaissent pas l'existence
du visage comme on peut on ressemble
travailler avec vos équipes et mes
équipes pour que l'on puisse réfléchir à
un webinaire ou à une organisation à
tous les Français il y a quand même 560
lycées dans le monde il y a plus de 5000
jeunes Français qui rentrent en France
après le bac et donc j'aimerais savoir
si on peut envisager de se rencontrer
pour pouvoir réfléchir ensemble pour que
je puisse communiquer avec vous avec les
ambassades les associations d'anciens
élèves les associations de parents de
parents d'élèves avec les proviseurs des
lycées les consulats pour pouvoir
communiquer sur le sujet
merci
du coup Evelyne Daniel salmon ensuite
Franck montoget
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur
vice-président et Madame le directrice
générale pour vous exposer
très très clair et votre votre cri
d'alarme dont on partage des constats
je reviendrai sur un point c'est celui
de la rénovation thermique loin de moi
l'idée d'opposer construction et
rénovation mais on sait que vous avez la
capacité dans le domaine des logements
sociaux d'aller très vite vous avez
prouver votre efficacité dans la
rénovation thermique et aujourd'hui on a
besoin d'accélérer
et je voudrais savoir quels sont vos
capacités de financement on voit bien
qu'elles sont très très impactées
aujourd'hui d'aller vite dans la
rénovation thermique ou est-ce que vous
en êtes est-ce que vous avez bénéficié
d'aide de l'État autre
je sais que vous soyez les particuliers
en droit ma prime de rénove qu'est-ce
qui qu'est-ce qui est fait pour le
logement social pour aider à cette
rénovation je vous vois bien sourire
mais j'attends de d'avoir votre réponse
et de quel besoin de financement
auriez-vous pour vous acquitter pour
aller dans le sens de cette rénovation
accélérée merci
Franck Montauger ensuite Denis boide
merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur et Madame
il y a quelques années à l'occasion des
premières mesures présentées par le
ministre de Normandie mon groupe
avait dit que en fait
s'engager un processus de casse du
modèle de l'habitat social en France je
pense qu'on y est aujourd'hui alors moi
je me réjouis pas qu'on soit plus
nombreux à le constater à le déplorer
mais je voulais quand même rappeler ça
discuter à l'époque on s'est senti un
peu seul je vous le cache pas voilà au
delà monsieur du constat que vous faites
et du cas particulier effectivement
important de ce que vous appelez
l'ursaffisation quel est votre
proposition de modèle de l'habitat
social en France dans un contexte de
transition climatique avec toutes les
obligations qui en découlent social
environnementales etc est-ce que vous
votre organisme met sur la table au
débat des des propositions pour refondre
refonder le modèle de l'habitat social
en France vous avez évoqué certains
points qui voilà qui relèvent de cette
de ce débat là mais je voudrais savoir
si vous avez une proposition de modèles
globale
sur sur ce point et ma deuxième question
elle est plus
plus ciblée
quels sont quel est votre action
si ce n'est vous positionne à l'égard
des territoires ruraux à deux égards
d'abord le logement social temporaire
pour les travailleurs agricoles
saisonniers pas forcément relevant du
RSA dont nous avons et dont nous aurons
besoin voilà et quel est votre
contribution
votre position ou vos réflexions par
rapport aux conséquences du zan pour les
communes rurales en particulier je pense
à la question de la réhabilitation de
l'habitat ancien dégradée ou délaissé
qui peut constituer une réponse par
rapport aux ânes pour de très très
nombreux villages
en zone rurale confrontée à la mise en
œuvre du zan je vous remercie
merci
Denis boîte ensuite Franck Menonville
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
Président je partage beaucoup de
l'analyse que vous avez pu faire sur la
crise du logement que nous traversons
aujourd'hui et je vous avoue comme vous
que je suis assez inqui pour l'avenir
depuis plusieurs années nous alertons
sur cette prise de logement ici qui ont
des principales facteurs d'inégalités
dans ce pays vous-même vous avez parlé
récemment de banque sociale moi j'en
prends le mot je penserai plutôt qu'une
fois un temps de marche à ce jour
logement social que plutôt des
réductions de RS
les logements sont de plus en plus
accessibles et des salariés sont
contraintes éloignés de leur habitation
de leur lieu de travail si la logique
voudrait que son nom qu'on choisisse son
logement en fonction de son emploi
aujourd'hui de plus en plus de pensées
doivent choisir leur emploi en fonction
de leur capte leur capacité à se loger
et on voit aujourd'hui des chaînes
d'entreprise que vous représentez qui
sont obligés de construire eux-mêmes des
logements pour leurs salariés
cette crise du logement des traductions
concrètes sur l'économie de nos
territoires alors que les entreprises
sur deux cherche du personnel certains
employeurs doivent faire face à des
difficultés de recrutement faute de
logement disponibles pour le logement
salariés à des prix raisonnables une
enquête publiée par la CPME le 15 mai
dernier indique que les salariés
renoncent en emploi portent de logement
adaptés la question du logement et des
mobilités professionnelles pourraient
donc être mieux accompagnés comment
appréhendez-vous ce sujet des
améliorations de la coordination avec
les élus locaux mais aussi avaient
l'ensemble des bailleurs sociaux sur les
territoires sont-elles envisageables
par ailleurs j'aurai une question de ma
collègue Viviane artigualas il ne peut
pas être là ce matin concernant le
dispositif mobili passe
qui a pour but de faciliter la mobilité
professionnelle des salariés actions
de ce dispositif au 30 juin 2023 nous
souhaitons connaître les raisons de
cette suppression et les dispositifs
éventuels pour les remplacer ou le faire
évoluer merci
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président Monsieur Louis Président
Madame la Directrice générale tout
d'abord vous remercier vous féliciter de
la clarté de vos propos et de la passion
qui est la vôtre pour porter vos
convictions je voudrais surtout apporter
moi un témoignage parce que finalement
ce que vous vivez c'est une nouvelle
fois une une fragilisation des décors
intermédiaires et des valeurs du du
paritarisme c'est aussi il faut le dire
le goût actuel de la recentralisation et
de la reprise en main de
l'administration sur un certain nombre
de politiques souvent avisé budgétaire
finalement et ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que dans les temps que nous vivons
actuels c'est justement l'inverse qu'il
faut faire il faut vraiment s'appuyer
sur le pari tarisme rechercher des
compromis c'est la culture de votre
groupe et moi ce que je voudrais surtout
dire à cet instant c'est témoigner pour
l'action qui était la vôtre qui est
l'action du groupe axiolagement dans
dans le cadre d'un département comme le
département de la Meuse ou nous avions
un OPH
qui représentait à peu près 10000 un
poids de 10000 logements qui étaient en
difficulté depuis de nombreuses années
parce que pas la taille critique pour
pour mener à bien ces ambitions et avec
bien évidemment des enjeux extrêmement
importants il y en a eu
l'intelligence collective d'une d'une
synergie de nos groupes en créant une
une sac avec comme l'avait fait
préalablement nos voisins aux marnais et
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on a retrouvé
des véritables capacités d'action dans
notre département pour rénover
construire assurer la transition
énergétique et vraiment je pense que
c'est des exemples comme ça qu'il faut
aussi porter et aussi valoriser sur
notre territoire parce que on voit le
vraiment j'allais dire le levier
financier le levier opérationnel levier
en matière de compétences que vous êtes
et qui peuvent s'adosser à la
territorialisation de pH comme les
nôtres qui ont qui sont vraiment
aujourd'hui parfaitement efficients
voilà merci
oui merci madame la Présidente merci
mesdames et messieurs de d'Action
Logement ma question vient compléter
celle de Daniel Salmon et elle concerne
le problème des passoires thermiques qui
s'applique depuis le premier janvier de
cette année
qui concerne aujourd'hui sur le plan
national que 2 % des logements les plus
mal isolés mais cette proportion valait
en augmentant avec
l'interdiction
l'impossibilité de loger enfin de mettre
en location les logements classés F et G
très vite à l'horizon de 2028 et moi je
voulais savoir quelle est la part
du parc d'immobilier Action Logement qui
est concerné par ces
logements classés F et G alors j'espère
très peu parce que la trajectoire
financière
qui s'offre enfin qui ce qui est devant
Action Logement peut rendre compliqué
la nécessaire rénovation énergétique de
ces logements voilà et donc quel est
quel est le pourcentage de ces logements
merci beaucoup Serge Sylviane Noël pour
terminer cette série merci madame la
Présidente et merci messieurs madame
pour la qualité de votre exposé qui ne
nous rassure pas et qui ne fait que
confirmer la volonté un peu
symptomatique de notre pays depuis
quelques années de détruire
systématiquement systématiquement pardon
ce qui marche et votre histoire nous
rappelle assez celle de l'agence de
l'eau qui s'est vu confisqué une partie
de ses ressources pour les verser dans
le tonneau des dalaïdes et c'est bien
regrettable j'avais pour ma part une
question concernant la proposition du
Président de la République détendre la
garantie visale à tous les propriétaires
sans condition est-ce que cela vous
paraît réalisable et tenable merci
merci
alors je vais d'abord répondre au
ministre monsieur le ministre concernant
les Adidas à Nil
on est en plein consensus sur ce type de
réponse évidemment au vu de la situation
financière vous imaginez bien que
certains d'entre nous autour de la table
du conseil d'administration de l'action
logement groupe était pour la
suppression de toutes les aides même si
nous reconnaissons l'utilité
indispensable des villes et des vanilles
mais Philippe Langrand la souligné tout
à l'heure les les discussions sont
modernes autour de la table et des
consensus sont trouvés donc sans vous
dévoiler à l'avance les montants que qui
seront attribués aux Adils et aux Adils
vous pouvez
rassurer vos interlocuteurs et leur dire
que nous avons entendu votre
vos
intérêts enfin vos intérêts pour cette
question des adultes et des anniv et que
nous serons si nous trouvons un accord
évidemment avec l'État extrêmement
bienveillant auprès d'eux voilà je peux
pas vous donner le montant exact là
puisque
vous avez entendu que nous allions être
bienveillants et que des montants
pourront être sauvegardés pour eux
voilà
donc de toute façon pour pour 2023 c'est
fait à qui puisque on l'a dit à la
Convention quinquennale le devait se
terminer au 31 décembre 2022 et que
l'année 2023 est une année de suivi mais
j'imagine que votre question portait sur
les années à venir voilà mais on les va
on les va pas oublier et le Paris tarif
va fonctionner et un consensus a été
trouvé
concernant le MOBILIPASS de façon
générale et pour répondre plus
clairement à Madame la fénatrice comme
le temps nous est compté je vous propose
que l'on puisse se rencontrer pour les
Français de l'étranger de façon
je vous propose de vous rencontrer comme
le temps là nous est compté je vous
propose de nous rencontrer on aura
l'occasion de venir avec les experts de
de cette question et puis pouvoir
évidemment mieux répondre aux 500.000
jeunes qui ont envie de revenir faire
les études sur le territoire
euh hexagonale donc aucune difficulté on
se voit très vite à disposition pour
rentrer pour rentrer dans le détail
concernant le MOBILIPASS les partenaires
sociaux ont
souhaité arrêter ce produit pour pour
deux raisons la première parce que
économiquement aujourd'hui il est pas
tenable et puis deux on souhaite faire
une proposition juste après la signature
ou pendant la signature de la convention
quinquennale sur un produit de mobilité
beaucoup plus dynamique beaucoup plus
précis et qui évitera toutes les fraudes
de microstructures qui ont pu être créés
pour bénéficier de ce produit là aussi
depuis l'arrivée de Nadia Bouyer il y a
une rigueur qui a été mise sur le
contrôle extrêmement précis de toute
fraude sur l'ensemble de nos produits et
donc il y aura évidemment puisque c'est
l'ADN d'Action Logement un produit de
mobilité qui sortira dans les mois qui
viennent et qui répondra avec encore
plus de de précisions à l'ensemble des
besoins de mobilité croissant de de
l'ensemble des des salariés mais
également des des jeunes
concernant la rénovation la rénovation
énergétique alors là aussi j'y mettrais
aussi la question des f et g
le parc d'Action Logement mais comme le
parc de l'ensemble des bailleurs sociaux
français et plutôt en meilleure état que
le parc du privé les bailleurs sociaux
travaillent depuis longtemps cette
problématique de la de la rénovation
énergétique et les filiales d'Action
Logement évidemment
peut-être peut-être encore plus que les
autres
rendre du pouvoir d'achat aux Français
passe aussi par la maîtrise de nos
charges et c'est un devoir de pouvoir
répondre à
ces sujets la problématique des FSG va
devenir
terrible parce que
malheureusement les bailleurs privés ou
petit bailleur ou bailleur personnel qui
mettent à disposition des logements qui
souvent correspondent à leur retraite ou
à leur compléments de retraite etc
n'auront pas les moyens
n'auront pas les moyens de revenir sur
des travaux extrêmement importants et
préférons pour beaucoup retirer ces
logements du de l'offre et comme on est
en manque d'offres déjà je vous imaginez
l'impact là aussi que que ça va avoir et
émettre des choses en place à très court
terme nous sommes nous favorables
évidemment parce que on souhaite aller
vite mais là aussi il faut mesurer les
impacts de toute chose donc je crains
que ça plus Lausanne mal maîtrisé ou mal
compris va accentuer encore les
problématiques que nous avons là je le
disais tout à l'heure 350 km heure en
klaxonnant mais ça le mur arrive très
vite
voilà concernant le modèle global que
nous pourrions
avoir au sein d'Action Logement sur le
logement social
vous savez je crois que malheureusement
il y a pas de baguette magique il y a
pas une seule solution il faut
évidemment utiliser
l'ensemble de l'Arsenal disponible en
France pour pouvoir répondre à cette
question qui est qui est majeure
un modèle unique j'avoue j'y crois pas
faire que de la construction j'y crois
pas on a beaucoup démoli on va démolir
un peu moins on a beaucoup démoli
notamment dans le cadre de de des qpv et
de la rue peut-être que nous allons
aller vers un modèle qui sera moins
orienté vers la déconstruction et la
reconstruction mais plus vers des
réhabilitations totales et majeures donc
ça répond ça répond à la question que
j'ai zappé tout à l'heure ma chère
Dominique qui qui constitue à avoir une
offre de seconde vie mais là aussi ça
peut pas faire 100% de des sujets et je
ferai je ferai un lien avec la question
que que Franck posait tout à l'heure
concernant la restructuration de notre
modèle
du modèle du logement social il citer en
creux une de nos filiales qui s'appelle
pluriales dans la sénatrice on connaît
bien puisque elle est Marneffe à
l'origine et aujourd'hui elle elle
se développe de de l'Est parisien
jusqu'au quasiment à la
Meurthe-et-Moselle en tout cas à la
Meuse incluse et de
le regroupement dans cette fac d'une f.h
extrêmement dynamique et de deux offices
qui est qui était plutôt bien géré mais
en difficulté parce que pas à la bonne
taille l'ensemble des trois l'ingénierie
qui a été apportée autour de ça donne
aujourd'hui une fac extrêmement
dynamique très importante et qui répond
beaucoup mieux aux besoins de nos
territoires donc merci d'avoir souligné
ce très bel exemple territorial qui qui
permet à des facteurs qu'on appelle
vulgairement détendu de de continuer à
avoir une offre extrêmement
extrêmement bienveillante pour pour nos
concitoyens
ensuite concernant les les territoires
ruraux
nous sommes territoriaux je le disais
donc on a des filiales sur la
quasi-totalité des départements et donc
là aussi on essaie d'avoir
grâce à la structure nationale cette
fois cette forte de
fonds qui nous permet d'investir
lourdement sur des territoires ruraux
plutôt que ce qui était fait à l'époque
où nous avions beaucoup de collecteurs
où il ne faisait que redistribuer ce qui
collectait donc lorsque vous étiez
métropolitain collecteur métropolitain
vous aviez des moyens très très
importants et quand vous étiez un
collecteur rural c'était extrêmement
difficile grâce aujourd'hui au
collecteurs unique on peut réinvestir de
façon massive c'est vrai pour les
territoires ruraux mais c'est vrai
également pour les territoires
ultramarins où je rappelle qu'action
logement à dédié une enveloppe d'un
milliard et demi d'investissement pour
les territoires es ultramarins qui nous
permet d'avoir aujourd'hui un opérateur
à Mayotte vivant sur évidemment l'Apec
collecté sur des territoires qui vont
mieux que les autres
je pense pas avoir expliqué grand chose
ah oui concernant Vival fait extrêmement
extrêmement important
une fois de plus le en même temps est
très compliqué parce que Vival est un
produit qui a été créé pour être
excusez-moi du terme mais discriminant
si vous le rendez universel une fois de
plus une fois de plus c'est dans
l'opposition totale ou antagonistes
puisque
seuls les jeunes
les moins de 30 ans et des salariés sous
plafond peuvent bénéficier de visa donc
à partir du moment où vous le rendez
universel un il a plus aucun intérêt
deux il va déresponsabiliser
nos concitoyens parce que là pour le
coup vous ne payez plus Action Logement
paiera vous détruisez votre logement
puisque Vidal intègre une garantie
qui qui permet de refaire l'ensemble
et puis le dernier point qui ne peut pas
fonctionner avec cette garantie
universelle c'est vous imaginez le
montant de la caution financière dans le
bilan d'Action Logement service qu'il
faudrait avoir pour garantir l'ensemble
de tout ça et puis au niveau éthique
entre nous est-ce que
mon fils unique j'adore plus que tout
doit bénéficier de la garantie vivale
est-ce que le père que je suis ne peut
pas assumer l'ensemble de ces garanties
donc voilà pourquoi on doit garder voilà
pourquoi on doit garder un produit pour
ceux qui en ont besoin un produit qui
est ciblé spécifique et extrêmement
efficace et vous l'avez dit madame la
sénatrice pourquoi une fois de plus
modifié abîmer ou arrêter un produit qui
fonctionne un million de rivals
distribués on en a fait un million c'est
fantastique ça marche bien gardant le
comité merci beaucoup
très bien merci beaucoup coup je vais
devoir mettre fin à cette audition
absolument passionnante merci de n'avoir
eu aucune langue de bois je pense que
les messages ont été correctement
passées et je pense que sans vouloir
Prée sur les positions des uns et des
autres vous pourrez trouver au Sénat le
soutien nécessaire voilà et assez
transpartisant sur
l'existence et la continuité de votre de
votre existence comme comme outil
partenarial extrêmement important et
fondamental dans le redressement de
notre pays voilà merci infiniment pour
cette pour cette audition merci beaucoup
et à très vite j'ai bien compris voilà
je vais demander à mes collègues deux
petites minutes voilà on a encore un
ordre du jour donc on va se